j'accueille elie wiesel
elie wiesel bonsoir bonsoir ça va oui
pour l'instant alors elie wiesel témoins
et survivant de l'holocauste défenseur
infatigable des droits de l'homme et
votre humanisme vous a valu en 1986 le
prix nobel de la paix
oui
c'est un peu l'émission de prix nobel
ici on avait shirin ebadi a quinze jours
donc on fait beaucoup dans le prix nobel
en ce moment extrêmement respectable
alors il y disait elle vous êtes né en
roumanie en 1928 à l'âge de 15 ans
s'était déporté à auschwitz puis à
buchenwald à 16 ans vous vous retrouvez
à paris vous n'avez ni famille ni pays
vous est pris en charge par une oeuvre
caritative et vous fait des études de
philosophie à la sorbonne mais vous
hésitez avec le conservatoire à ce
moment là pourquoi avoir choisi la
philosophie parce que bon j'aurais aimé
être chef d'orchestre
parce que quand on chante orchestria il
ya quand même une écoute l'histoire que
moi j'avais à dire
cette pente bichi que je pouvais la d il
fallait des mots ouais donc le moment de
la création de l'état d'israël vous
embarqué à marseille pour haifa mais en
arrivant vous êtes déçus par le regard
que les jeunes israéliens portent sur
les survivants des camps et vous décidé
de revenir à paris
je n'étais pas prêt c'est une sorte
d'engagement spirituellement j'étais lié
à jérusalem
je suis resté mais pour y vivre je
n'étais pas prêt je faisais partie je
pense je fais partie de la diaspora
juive pandore discret et mais israël
d'ailleurs mes jeunes mistral vous
revenez à paris où vous devenez
journalistes mais témoigner de ce que
vous avez vécu devient une véritable
obsession et vous écrivez votre premier
livre la nuit à main nue strict départ
m'intéresse pas beaucoup les éditeurs on
s'est battus scriabine été refusée
rejetée par tous les grands éditeurs de
paris en suis de new york du monde
entier ouais c'est françois mauriac qui
finalement avait réussi à le placer aux
éditions de minuit
et voilà c'est ainsi que ses sorties en
mais pourquoi ce manuscrit qui est
excellent avait été refusé par tous il
disait premièrement est divisé la scène
auteur d'un livre
il restera il ne dira jamais autre chose
deuxièmement miss pas trop triste
on en parle des choses tristes
18 il se faisait vrai ils préfèrent
autre chose divertissement s'était pas
en vivre pour divertir
ouais enfin livre sur votre expérience
dans les camps alors ce livre qui est le
premier de 47 autres l'animatrice
américaine oprah winfrey en a parlé il
ya quelques mois dans son célèbre talk
show aux états unis et 45 ans après sa
publication
ce livre est devenu numéro 1 de la liste
des best-sellers du new york times
depuis neuf semaines
oui à mon grand étonnement mais vous
savez moi j'avais cédé tous mes droits
aux éditions de minuit dont je ne savais
pas ce qui se passait avec ce livre là
un c'est après que j'avais découvert que
même avoir oprah winfrey
ce livre avait été vendue en 6 millions
d'exemplaires relation de poche 1 mais
c'est elle qui l'a lancé de nouveau avec
une nouvelle traduction fête papa ma
femme et elle a vendu je pense eumelio
réduit en deux mois mais c'est donc le
livre sans lequel je n'aurais rien écrit
dans cet incroyable qu'un livre qui
était refusé par tous les grands
éditeurs du monde se soit vendu depuis à
des millions d'exemplaires et soit de
nouveau un succès des commandes à la
télévision c'est sans doute quelqu'un
quand vous qui peut l'ancien livre je
sais pas ça nous arrive oui en tout cas
elle offre une voiture chaque membre du
public erp pas toujours et ailleurs une
fois la fais ça par mois ça tirait bien
sur
vous n'aurez ans longtemps sur le
camping vous aurez une belle 5 alors
vous êtes ici elie wiesel pour votre
dernier livre qui paraît au seuil qui
s'appelle un désir fou de danser alors
c'est l'histoire d'un juif vieillissant
qui souffre d'un excès de mémoire et qui
craint d'avoir basculé dans la folie et
qui va voir une psychanalyste alors elle
va l'aider en fait à révéler son
douloureux passé familial jusqu'à
retrouver un souvenir enfoui qui lui
permet à lui de comprendre pourquoi il
s'est toujours condamné au célibat et à
la souffrance
c'est quelqu'un qui était fou mais un
fou qui sait qu'il est fou est il fou
est-ce que c'est lui qui est fou ou est
ce que c'est le monde qui est fou et lui
qui est sain n'en sais rien voilà moi
aussi après
en tous les cas elle est quand même à
trouver la clé de son problème une scène
que nous ne raconterons pas évidemment
mais quittons fouiller dans son passé
entre sa mère et un homme quoi seul rond
de la thérapeute cherchait des fouilles
et elle fouille et elle fouille à trous
n est pas tout à fait parce qu'elle de
secrets en lui qui restent secrets
enfouis dans dans son amour à sa mémoire
et à la fin seulement il ya un
dénouement bien sûr résolution grâce
infinie
il ya toujours un fou dans vos romans
mais ici le fou c'est le personnage
principal quoi quand on est fou ouais
mais ils m'adorent aussi alors moi j'ai
des contacts avec eux ils m'écrivent des
lettres et de l'entrée de la laiterie
parfois ça prend des mois alors la
première lettre j'aime intéressante
les trois ça revient deux fois cinq fois
c'est un peu difficile parce que que
faire le fou n'a qu'une histoire à
raconter
mais il raconte cinq fois et bras il
faut que je réponde cinq fois j'avais
beaucoup comme ça a beaucoup énormément
comme j'écris sur les faux ils pensent
que je supplie canalis a réussi quatre
bris ne suit pas vous êtes juste fou un
fou pour les autres
alors lui pense est tombé sous
l'influencé diabolique d'un dibbouk
ouais alors indices books et une âme
errante qui ne peut se sentir en
sécurité que au sein d'une autre âme
quoi oui c'était une réduction dans
cette arène habitent-ils envahi cet
envahisseur qui avait et qui prend
contrôle qui prend le pouvoir presque
sur la sueur sur cette personne donc
c'est vrai que donc mon personnage
principal se prend pour quelqu'un qui
est habitée par l'ibook voilà vous avez
dit un livre est un bon livre par le
poids de son silence ça veut dire quoi
or ce parce qu'un livre n'est pas
seulement fait de mots oui c'était aussi
le silence c'est l'espace qui partage
les mots et quand il ya beaucoup de
silence un vrai silence par un silence
qui doivent protester contre une
injustice une silence métaphysique
là ce n'est pas du livre qui sont qui
s'en sert et qui sort en régie dans tous
mes livres c'est comme ça mais livre
commence toujours par avoir de centaines
de pages et le coup et je coupe j'ai
lavé j'ai l'âge est toujours qu'en
disant je je je fais tomber quelques
pages elle reste mais invisible 1 c'est
le silence et cépages pires le cri n'ont
poussé le plus fort justement ce prix du
silence le silence un cri de me crie
silencieux très très fort il faut être
disant sensible à ce silence à ce cri si
on crie c'est fini oui on s'est libéré
de ce crime
mais si on le retient on vit avec
wizzit j'ai le sentiment maintenant que
je sais tout mais que je ne comprends
rien mais ce qui est vrai ouais même
quand j'écris et je pense avoir
l'expliqué des shows vrai que le lecteur
se débrouille vous comprendre moi je
comprends pas je comprends pas parce que
les choses les questions essentielles de
l'existence vaste question et
en vérité n'est pas de répondre pourquoi
le mal pourquoi la cruauté
pourquoi la haine surtout on vit
maintenant à une époque où la haine
domine le monde entier et si tu es l'un
des fanatiques et de tout mon arme de
tout mon coeur je suis contre le
fanatisme où qu'ils soient et quels
qu'ils soient
le 20e siècle a été dominée par le
fanatisme politique à moscou et raciale
à berlin le 28 ème siècle est déjà
dominé par le fanatisme religieux comme
au moyen âge
alors que faut-il faire resté silencieux
non il faut protester bien c'est tous
les moyens à notre disposition
alors l'oncle du héros est un juif
ultra-orthodoxe donc anti sioniste
puisque les juifs ultra orthodoxes sont
contre l'existence de l'état d'israël
ils disent c'est au messie d'instaurer
l'état juif
il faut pas le faire avant que le
messine le fasse et l'état d'israël est
une offense aux seniors une faute une
tragédie alors quand vous voyez ce qui
se passe au moyen-orient
est ce que vous pensez pas que
finalement c'est eux qui ont raison non
non ça évidemment pas mal ils n'ont pas
raison parce que je peux citer d'autres
textes contre les leurs ou prouver que
parfois il faut agir sur le destin et
sur l'histoire et précipitée et donc
c'est pas du mi6 israël par le messie
c'est simplement un besoin de répondre à
une quête une quête souveraineté
autrefois il y avait quand même état
souverain royaume en palestine et le
temple a été détruit deux fois peuple
juif a été exilé partout dans le monde
pour fait 30 arrivée après surtout après
un grand tragédie du xxème siècle se
retrouver souverain sur une terre
ancestrale
ouais donc il ya un vieux peuple avec
une nation très jeune voilà le problème
quand vous voyez le ramasse vous pensez
pas que c'est inextricable la situation
là bas oui
la surface oui parce que le ramasser
quoi on dit maintenant avec l'habitude
avec la victoire de famas 3 hamas était
une protestation contre arafat et la
corruption de fattar ceux qui sont dotés
vrai mais en vérité le programme de
ramasse est centrée sur un point
principal la destruction d'israël
donc ceux qui ont voté pour hamas il
faut le dire avec toute la douleur du
monde
ils ont voté pour la destruction
d'israël malgré tout je suis optimiste
je crois qu'il ramasse changera tout
sinon de contenu et sharon à la fin un
avant sa maladie était moi j'étais
convaincu je voulais pas les jeux les
interroger sharon était pour une
solution de deux états vivant en paix
donc la palestine et israël vivant côte
à côte tous les autres problèmes
pouvaient être résolus et l'aller les
résoudre avec des sacrifices et la même
idée les faire et je pense que son
successeur est haut dans le main par
faire la même chose quand vous apprenez
l'existence d'une bombe islamique en
iran est ce que vous restez toujours
aussi optimiste
maintenant le danger c'est les six et
l'iran parce que le chef politique
religieux de l'iran se passe mais jen
déjà dit jeanne est fou mais
pathologiquement malades food and les
condyles dit qu'il veut une bombe pour
détruire israël il incombe de le croire
donc que faire
partout on nous dit n'est ce pas ça
prendra quelques années de trois en
trois ans peut-être pour qu'il a eus
m'ont mais c'est une bombe qui va
menacer pas seulement il serait qu'il
peut menacer le monde entier ça peu
risqué quand même ça risque de provoquer
une guerre une sorte de complot création
nucléaire israël restera pas tranquille
s'il bon tel aviv
que pensez vous qu'israël ferait east
elle lit portrait c'est plus facile
d'arrêter hitler en 39 que le président
iranien aujourd'hui parce que il n'y
avait pas deux milliards de personnes
derrière lui alors qu'aujourd'hui ce
serait le cas exactement 1 exactement
sittler maintenant le sait pas le
document ne sont pas des archives on
aurait pu arrêter hitler parce que même
les l'état-major un an espère et des
sports qui se serait arrêté
et bien aujourd'hui avec l'iran ce pas
si simple israël avait détruit le pôle
réacteurs nucléaires de l'irak
c'est plus facile aux irradiés race de
plus facile il y avait d'un déclin ce
réacteur est visible il rend à 14h14
souterrain dans des centres urbains donc
attaquer ces actes là qui sait combien
de vies ça coûterait est ce que vous
pensez que l'homme évolue ou qu'il est
toujours aussi barbare qui est des
millénaires je vous dirai ce qui me fait
espérer quand même le gars 50 60 70
euros
autant de l'horreur il y avait très peu
de comités internationaux tous les
droits de l'homme ouais aujourd'hui
après deux mille cinq cents et partout
m'achever et moi je me rends pas
d'habitude ne s'est pas au aux endroits
où ça se passe je trouve toujours des
jeunes qui sont passionnés pour les
droits de l'homme qui quittent leur
bureau qui quittent leurs parents qui
quittent leurs billes coin pour aller
travailler pour les victimes et ses
nobles et c'est cette mission noble
assumé par les jeunes
et moi je vis dans un monde jeune je
suis enseignant je peux vous dire que ça
pour moi en tout cas ça pue raisons
d'espérer
alors venez voir à pétra en jordanie la
conférence des prix nobel sur la
sécurité le développement du monde vous
allez y participer c'est important c'est
utile 13 pourtant on a fait des gens une
fois ça vient après en 1988
j'avais fait avec mitterrand oui moi je
mentionnais gt et c'était une grande
pour la lecture encore amis du terroir
et moi [__] c'est avant vous
découvriez qu'il était ami bousquet
aussi est exactement avant et alors le
roi jordanien pas un ami commun vous
affirmez me demander si je me fais la
même chose avec lui on a fait pour
l'année dernière en juin
mais fin mai nous avions déjà une
conférence le titre était face à un
monde en danger on avait 30 propre prix
nobel quelques chefs d'état ouais et
pendant trois jours
c'était une grande discussion une bonne
discussion sur l'état du monde
maintenant on va leur faire de nouveau
le 20 21 22 juin toujours à petra avec
le roi et moi même donc moi j'y crois
quand vous avez un prix nobel un groupe
ii prix nobel il ya une écoute pour des
raisons que j'ignore où pas le prix
lamballe à ce prestige personne ne le
sait mais il ya ce prestige parce que
nous présente nous représentons vraiment
une autorité morale
tu me prendre dans l'espace aux
autorités que nous dirons moral et
l'avenir aussi peut-être qu'à l'avenir
enfin que le monde soit dirigé par un
conseil des sages et j'allais dire c'est
exactement la question laurent on et off
branché mais on est on est un peu
logique et on a un peu d avoir encore et
on espère beaucoup dans les gens comme
vous quoi pensez pas que ce serait bien
si le monde était dirigée par un conseil
des sages comme le relève de science
fiction
ces deux prix lambert dirige le manceau
serait pas pire
un désir de danser vos éditions du seuil